thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video find out more later on
hey 42 here if you're struggling to
think of something unusual but
eye-wateringly expensive to buy for your
better half for christmas this year
why not consider a piece of jewelry made
of mammoth tusk
i'm not talking about a hairy elephant
who's fallen behind in his manscaping
i mean the tusk of a genuine woolly
mammoth
the type that roamed the planet 30 000
years ago
most of the stores selling these sorts
of trinkets are located in hong kong
but if you're the 50 type who likes to
cut out the middleman you might want to
head straight to the source
siberia
there millions of buried mammoth
skeletons are being revealed as climate
change gradually melts the ground around
them
but as undeniably fashionable as woolly
mammoth tusk earrings may be
unfortunately for us it's not just hairy
pachyderms that are emerging from the
ice in siberia
now we all like traveling don't we and
do you know what's good for travelling
the fastest and easiest vpn surf shop
did you know surf shock helps you to
avoid price discrimination based on your
location so you actually save money on
plane tickets and car rentals whilst
traveling
surf shock runs on any device anywhere
and it's packed full of features such as
industry-leading uncrackable encryption
ip and dns leak protection an internet
kill switch if your vpn drops out and 24
7 customer support not forgetting it's
super easy to install and you can run it
on unlimited devices on a single
subscription i've personally been using
surfshark for a long time now to watch
netflix content from other countries
such as the us that's usually blocked
here in the uk it's so easy all i do is
switch over my location setting and
there i have it i've got access to all
my favorite programs surfshop maintains
a strict no log policy and their network
of 3200 servers in over 65 countries
runs completely unwrapped so they
physically can't log your data by using
the code 42 you'll benefit from an 83
percent discount plus four extra months
for free during the holiday period only
that's the 1st of november to the 31st
of december all you have to do is click
the special link in the description
below don't miss out
unless you've spent the last 10 years
marooned on an isolated polynesian
island living off ground seashells mixed
with your own urine
you'll know that apparently climate
change is one of the most present perils
facing humanity today its most commonly
described symptoms include frequent and
intense droughts heat waves storms and
warming oceans
melting sea ice and receding glaciers
have been reported widely
but one
charming knock-on effect of climate
change you might be less familiar with
is the arctic permafrost that's pouring
faster than a snowman in a sauna
permafrost is soil that's being
continually frozen for at least two
years and it covers around 11 of the
earth's surface including substantial
areas of canada greenland alaska and
siberia speaking of siberia that's where
the oldest permafrost on record can be
found it froze about 650 000 years ago
and hasn't fought out since
but
that might all be about to change the
arctic is warming twice as fast as the
rest of the globe in 2020 the highest
ever temperature in the arctic circle
was recorded in verkhoyansk siberia a
vodka warming 38 degrees
incidentally that's the same as the
hottest day ever recorded in the uk but
in an area that regularly sees the
mercury dropping below minus 30 degrees
celsius
permafrost is usually protected by a
surface layer of soil and sediment known
as the active layer that falls in summer
and re-freezes in winter
but now some parts of this layer don't
freeze at all so the permafrost
underneath is exposed to warmer
temperatures and is itself beginning to
fall
as it does so we're uncovering things
that have been buried and preserved for
tens of thousands of years that's why
you can now buy mammoth tusk earrings
but could it also spell the start of a
new pandemic
because alongside animal skeletons and
lung ferguson plant species the melting
permafrost is releasing diseases that
have been lying dormant for millennia
permafrost contains a lot of biomass
dead and living things including plants
animals and humans
but what's also locked into this
underground ice tomb is the mad mix of
pathogens viruses and bacteria that
existed at the time those animals and
humans died
in many cases they're nestled inside the
organism they actually killed bacteria
for example have developed numerous
strategies for surviving in temperatures
below zero degrees
including reduced anaerobic metabolic
processes which basically allows them to
go into slow motion they're a bit like
han solo in return of the jedi
frozen but alive waiting for their
chance to rejoin the bacteria rebel
alliance
when plants and animals die in cold
regions they don't always decompose
immediately or totally sometimes they
move down through the active layer and
into the permafrost
when more animals and plants are loaded
on top everything's pressed down even
further and deposits accumulate the
permafrost can be anything up to a
kilometer and a half thick in some
places
and the biomass at the bottom can be
hundreds of thousands of years old
with the increased flooring of the
permafrost below the surface bacteria
and viruses are able to make their way
to the active layer
and the deeper the fore the older the
organisms that awaken from their slumber
as for what exactly is down there
we basically have no idea but whatever
it is
it's probably headed our way soon
in fact it's heading our way right now
in 2016 an anthrax outbreak was
triggered after a heat wave accelerated
the permafrost four anthrax the pathogen
not the band is as bad as it sounds
actually the band's pretty awful too the
disease is caused by bacillus anaphrosis
a bacteria which is commonly found in
soil and has some delightful symptoms
like skin lesions diarrhea abdominal
pains nausea vomiting
and death
it's quite rare and before the 2016
outbreak it was thought to have been
eradicated in siberia at least 70 years
ago but then the foreign permafrost
revealed a long dead reindeer whose
corpse was infected with bacillus
anaphysis
the bacteria is thought to have spread
to the soil water and food supply of
nearby reindeer infecting approximately
2 000 of them
a 12 year old boy died and a further 100
people were hospitalized after the
outbreak crossed over to humans
thankfully that's where things ended but
over a million russian reindeer are
recorded to have died from anthrax in
the 20th century alone and their remains
are buried in shallow graves all over
the country's northern territories that
probably explains why santa's slay team
doesn't feature any egos or ivans
as the permafrost continues to melt
these reindeer carcasses could be
ticking anthrax time bombs but believe
it or not
that's far from scientists worst fear
smallpox is a vicious disease that was
declared eradicated in 1980 but not
before it killed as many as 500 million
people in the 20th century alone
anyone infected with the disease had a
chance of dying
which makes covert 19 look like a bad
cold
the variola virus that causes smallpox
is particularly hardy and can survive
extremely long periods of time
even when frozen
it continues to exist officially at
least in two highly secure places
vector laboratories in russia which
housed secret biological weapons
research during the soviet era and now
babysits everything from smallpox to
ebola and the centers for disease
control and prevention in the united
states every few years experts at the
world health assembly debate whether to
destroy these remaining samples as they
did in 2019 when a gas explosion at
vector made everyone feel more than a
little uneasy about a sudden outbreak of
the plague but each time these debates
happen the decision to destroy smallpox
forever is postponed it turns out though
that getting rid of all the world's lab
samples of smallpox might not help
anyway because the current and ongoing
foreign of the not not-so-perma frost
looks set to expose some lung buried
specimens of the contagion
in the 1890s 40 percent of a siberian
town's population was wiped out by a
smallpox epidemic and the corpses were
buried in the upper layer of permafrost
on the banks of the columbia river
this particular area is now known to be
foreign and the flood waters of the
river are consequently eroding the banks
at an even greater pace than before
riverbanks across siberia were often
places where nomads would bury their
dead so the plausibility of
disease-ridden cadavers bobbing along in
rivers like rotten toffee apples
certainly isn't far-fetched
scientists from the state research
center of virology and biotechnology in
nova sebersk tested remains of the stone
age bodies discovered in southern
siberia they also tested 19th century
corpses that had been buried during
various modern epidemics
though the researchers didn't extract
the smallpox virus itself
they did detect fragments of smallpox
dna and many of the corpses displayed
the sores characteristic of smallpox
of course even though outbreaks of
anthrax or smallpox would be terrible
they probably wouldn't mean the end of
humankind we've dealt with these
diseases fairly recently in our medical
history and have vaccines for both
but what about the bacteria and viruses
that we don't know about and have no
defenses against
woolly mammoths were roaming the earth
32 000 years ago during the pleistocene
period
novel bacteria from this time named
carnobacterium plesocenium
was recently discovered by researchers
from nasa in a frozen alaskan pond
scarily this bacteria was able to be
revived simply by melting the ice in
which it was encased
not so scarily it wasn't actually
harmful though it has close relatives
that cause disease in fish
which is only a slight evolutionary
shimmy away from something that could
cause diseases in humans
as recently as 2004 scientists
discovered a new giant virus named pifo
virus sibericum which had been frozen
for 30 000 years but was still
metabolically active when it was found
this particular sample from siberia was
discovered at a depth of only 30 meters
into the frozen ground
and as soon as it falled it became
infectious once again
the good news is unless you're an amoeba
this virus is just as harmless to humans
as carnobacteria and plesoscenium but
the family it belongs to
does include some candidates that can be
dangerous to us so we'll have to wait
and see
what else the permafrost reveals
the oldest known ice on earth forms part
of a glacier located in the beacon and
mullens valleys of antarctica
there researchers from rutgers
university in the usa claimed to have
revived bacteria that ranges from a
relatively young 100 000 years old up to
a mind-blowing 8 million years old
again none of the organic life forms
found by the team pose an existential
threat to humans but they do offer a
hint as to just how much
previously unknown biological history
lies buried deep in the earth's freezer
waiting for its day in the sun
and not everything we've found so far
has been entirely harmless
four million year old bacteria
discovered in new mexico was resistant
to 70 percent of available antibiotics
and was able to totally inactivate many
of them
having said all that i should point out
that the scientific community remains
divided on just how big a threat dormant
pathogens in the foreign permafrost may
be to us
when these popsicle microbes are finally
let loose they're exposed to oxygen and
sunlight which is very bad for them so
if they're going to successfully wipe
out the human race they're going to need
to find a suitable host as soon as
possible but the arctic is relatively
sparsely populated and many of the
people who live there have somewhat
limited contact with the outside world
so even if some enterprising prehistoric
disease is able to infect us humans any
outbreaks would probably be contained
certainly with more reason an outbreak
in oh i don't know the largest city in
central china wuhan
still mining and drilling operations to
exploit natural resources in the arctic
are being ramped up with every passing
year which not only increases the chance
of pathogen release from the permafrost
but also increases the number of
potential hosts in that area
just one infected person would allow the
virus to replicate
and by now it's safe to say we have a
pretty good idea of how things might pan
out from there especially since workers
in remote locations are often fly in fly
out and so any diseases would quickly
spread to more densely populated areas
along with more human activity in the
arctic we can expect more movement of
animals like birds and insects too
excellent vectors for disease
warmer temperatures can encourage new
plant growth where there was ice before
this in turn brings new birds and other
animals many of which are known to
migrate huge distances
the world's ecosystem is complex and in
flux
it's impossible to predict just what may
happen when a virus begins to spread
depending on who you listen to the
chances of humanity being infected with
a deadly prehistoric virus are either
somewhat improbable or impossible to
ignore to be on the safe side though i
suggest you stick to the basics of good
winter health
don't eat yellow snow and always test
your reindeer for anthrax
thanks for watching